here lies a forge filled with giants
flame that can burn the Earth tree
naturally such as sacrilegious threat
had to be removed so the Giants and
their fell God were slain but the fire
would not die so a sect of monks were
appointed to watch over it here in the
mountaintops where the flame terrified
and obsessed them these large enemies
are their prelate commanders who whipped
the monks into a religious fervor one
prolate named Barack took this role so
seriously that he severed his own head
fashioning it into a candle stand which
he hoped would ignite a stronger faith
in his men nevertheless a monk named
Eamon turned traitor and abandoned his
post in fear only to become enthralled
by the god-slaying black flame instead
and a monk named Adan stall a Giant's
flame incantation and he ran all the way
to Leonia with his fellow fire monks in
Hot Pursuit for the incantation he stole
hides a secret and it's that the Fel God
was never truly defeated though it lives
on in the eye of the beholder